im bild berichtet bereits seit drei
wochen aus weißrussland aus - zunächst
von gewalt dann von hoffnung und jetzt
erneuter unterdrückung die vergangenen
tage wurden massenhaft menschen
festgenommen journalisten die
akkreditierung entzogen
die der drucker fabriken ausgeübt und
putin hält seine mörder truppen jetzt
bereit um das minsker regime im kampf zu
unterstützen lukaschenko klammert sich
weiterhin an die macht doch dennoch
gehen trotzdem immer wieder tausende
menschen auf die straße transporter ohne
kennzeichen mit denen demonstranten
verschleppt werden brutale spezialkräfte
und armeefahrzeuge auf den straßen
weißrussland erlebt eine neue eskalation
um die zukunft von diktator alexander
lukaschenko
doch sie lassen sich davon nicht mehr
einschüchtern
wir haben keine angst also die menschen
kommen und sie möchten also trafen die
menschen ja und wir möchten also unseren
präsidenten selbst wählen also wenn man
die wahl den menschen mitgehen das es
aber viele polizei
hunderttausende plant das jetzt kommt er
als 26 jahren angst gehabt und so tage
gibt es schon nicht gar nichts mehr als
100.000 demonstranten sind am sonntag in
minsk wieder auf den straßen gewesen
viele werden verhaftet verschleppt wohin
weiß keiner genau
doch die menschen in belarus gehen
weiter auf die straßen fordern ihre
freiheit
doch im moment ist klug anstellt relativ
sicher im amt insbesondere wegen der
unterstützung von russlands präsident
wladimir putin die lage in belarus ist
weiterhin angespannt es bleibt offen wie
die proteste weitergehen und ob
lukaschenko tatsächlich bereit ist sie
blutig niederzuschlagen
und in minsk ist noch immer bild vize
paul ronzheimer die vier menschen waren
da gestern wieder auf der straße ist
dann waren erneut mehr als 100.000
menschen hier in minsk alleine auf der
straße im ganzen land hunderttausende
insgesamt der fokus auf der journalisten
ist ja meistens die hauptstadt aber in
den regionen gab es auch großen großen
protest gestern eigentlich genau
vergleichbar mit dem die es auch lebten
sonntag gegeben hat aber das ist auch so
ein bisschen das problem nele es gibt
hier einmal die woche diesen riesen
contest und dann ist es wieder ruhig wie
heute heute morgen sieht man hier auf
den straßen nicht mehr haben gerade den
beitrag schon gehört lukaschenko wird
von putin jetzt gestärkt er hat ihn
seine hilfe zugesichert wie groß ist
also die chance demonstranten
tatsächlich jetzt noch für einen umbruch
sich einsetzen zu können dass sie es
wirklich noch schaffen lukaschenko nicht
mehr als ihren präsidenten zu haben
es wird immer schwieriger für die
demonstranten hier ihre hoffnung
durchzusetzen lukas schenkel loszuwerden
das muss man ganz realistisch so sehen
denn dann denke ich hatte sich putin am
anfang nach den gefälschten wahlen erst
zurückgehalten und hat sich die
situation hier angeschaut und jetzt hört
man fast täglich nachrichten dass
wladimir putin mit alexander lukaschenko
telefoniert hat gestern hat er ihm ganz
offiziell den geburtstag gratuliert und
offenbar ist putin taktik dass es ihm
lieber ist einen schwachen diktator hier
im land zu haben als einen
demokratischen weg der dann am ende
bedeuten könnte dass auch die menschen
in moskau in ganz russland sehen dass es
eine chance gibt das könnte der eine
grund sein warum putin zu ihm hält und
der zweite grund könnte sein dass der
große traum von wladimir putin schon
immer war weißrussland und russland
zusammen zu führen also ein reich zu
schaffen möglich dass lukas schenke ihm
das für die nahe zukunft zu sagen musste
damit er in unterstützt das sind aber
spekulation
wenn es jetzt schwieriger wird für die
demonstranten denkst du oder merkt man
langsam dass die stimmung kippt oder
werden sie jetzt auch am nächsten
wochenende wieder in diesen großen
zahlen auf die straße gehen
nein das ist
sicher ist dass die menschen sich das
nicht anmerken lassen wenn man hier auf
der straße unterwegs ist und sagt aber
wie wollt ihr das schaffen haben wir
keine angst gestern war ich bei der demo
dabei und hab gesehen wie auf der einen
seite die truppen kamen und menschen
einkassiert haben wahllos menschen
festgenommen haben aber auf der anderen
seite ein paar straßen weiter wieder
tausende auf die straße gegangen sind
und wenn man dann stark habt ihr angst
warum habt ihr eigentlich keine angst
dann sagen sie 26 jahre lukaschenko
waren genug und es sieht so aus als
wollen sie weitermachen es gibt für
morgen zumindest den plan dass es seine
art streik gibt und am sonntag
sicherlich wieder groß proteste dennoch
muss man ganz realistisch sagen es sieht
so aus es fehlt in so ein bisschen die
strategie wenn ich das vergleiche zum
beispiel mit der ukraine auch wenn die
situation nicht vergleichbar ist was die
ein wunsch der menschen angeht aber wenn
ich nur die proteste miteinander
vergleiche dann war es so dass es dort
eine zeltstadt gab das ist dort jeden
tag proteste gab und das ist einen
starken anführer gab und den gibt es
ganz offensichtlich hier nicht